but it's so good I want to cry it like
literally fills my whole body like you I
could just hit so many different flavors
on your time hi my name is on the day
I'm a day and today we're gonna be
picking my dad's recipe for chilaquiles
she like us are the quintessential
Mexican breakfast they're a bed of
crispy fried tortillas in a red sauce
served with a peg topped with avocado
cilantro queso fresco and it's delicious
chilaquiles really remind me of my
childhood I remember hanging out with my
dad and helping him make me some make
the family Sam and I remember him when
you all live together under one roof and
we would get together every Sunday I
need to you like he lives everyone has
like a really unique way of making them
and I'm pretty partial my dad dads
because they have that little bit of
crunch but they also have a lot of sauce
in Los Angeles it's pretty easy to find
ridiculous you can pretty much go to any
Mexican restaurant but nobody makes them
as good as my dad my dad is really
thoughtful really kind he's a sweetheart
he really taught me how to be kind and
gentle with family with friends with
animals I know he's taught me so much
about life he was born and raised in
Mexico a lot of Mexican culture and
grain in him which is one of the reasons
I love him so much at the same time it's
kind of been hard for our relationship I
would say to myself discovery journey
like about a year ago I started taking
estrogen and transitioning to be the
beautiful person I am today but I think
that my transition actually opened up a
lot of doors for that relationship we
started talking about a lot of things
that we usually didn't I like that clear
culture is like a hodgepodge of so many
different types of people kind of like
to like you guys there's a bunch of
different ingredients that look a lot
different tastes a lot different that
you have to treat them in a very special
way
hmm so good oh yes
you